the reason that I feel confident about
this book that's coming out is I wrote
19 drafts of the book four full rewrites
end to end and it's six hours a day from
6 a.m till noon every day for two years
to get this book to where it is now when
I was done with the book I was like
there's nothing else I can do to this
like I can't make it simpler I can't
make it shorter I can't cut it I can't
add a visual that I should have added
it's done and sort of the same degree
with the presentation that I have I gave
myself this framework of like okay well
if I were to speak in front of 10 000
people I would probably spend a good
amount of time prepping the presentation
to make sure it was good only speak in
front of 500 000. every single day I do
a full draft say the presentation in my
head and then I do a second run where I
say it out loud and I record it and then
after I record it I play the recording
with the slides up and I fix every slide
where I Stumble or there's something
that should be there or Visual and I
keep going until there's not much else I
can do to it and then when I get up
there it doesn't matter if the tech
doesn't work or if the book shopping
page doesn't work or whatever it is
because I'll be able to step off stage
and look in the mirror and be like you
did everything you could